this week marked the sixth anniversary
of the uk leaving the european union
and it's all going very well according
to the architect of boris johnson's
trade deal in a speech this week to mark
the anniversary lord frost said that
brexit is working and anyone who says
otherwise must have an axe to grind
but he did admit that the northern
ireland protocol remained
what he called unfinished business
well let's see if we can um
get any closer to the finishing line
because joining me now is the european
union's ambassador to the uk
vale de almeida um good morning
ambassador um
any chance that
we might be able to resolve this problem
can you see a way through
we remain very much committed to that we
want to find a way out
i'm afraid the government's track uh is
maybe probably unfortunately a road to
nowhere and and we would like to avoid
that when you say it's a road to nowhere
you you basically just dismissed what
they what they're proposing i mean
um
mr lewis has told told us that there's
going to be a new bill and
he's going to try to deal with the
practical problems and so on are you
just simply dismissing what they've
offered no we're not dismissing but we
we read it very carefully and we think
to be very frank we think it is both
illegal and unrealistic it is illegal
because it's it's a breach of
international law
a breach of eu law uk law and
international law it's a treaty that we
signed ratified and even went through a
general election in this country we also
believe it is unrealistic because it
does not provide the real
alternative to the protocol you know we
had long negotiations so trying to sort
of square the circle around the problems
created by brexit and the kind of brexit
that was chosen in northern ireland none
of us british side our side could find
anything other than this platform to try
to address those issues we are committed
to find the the practical solutions on
implementation but we cannot start
talking if the if the if the baseline is
to say everything we are that we
have agreed before
is to be put aside so so we're at
stalemate really aren't we
for the moment we are for the moment we
are but let me say that we are very
committed to finding solutions we've
been to northern ireland several times
we talk all the time to northern ireland
stakeholders as much as we talk to our
interlocutors here in london and i think
we found
solutions for the problems or the main
problems that we found in implementing
this protocol we are about to reduce our
label and willing to reduce by 80
the sanitary checks by 50 the paperwork
on people you know normally if we apply
the rules by the book a lordy that
carries different kinds of goods will
have hundreds of pages of paperwork we
have reduced it to less than three pages
per lorry
but
there has to be controls because this is
about
as much as protecting the good friday
agreement to which we are very committed
but it's also about protecting the
single market of the european union all
right well we'll watch this space um
let's turn to
one of the biggest stories still and
that is ukraine it's um announced this
week that ukraine has been granted eu
candidate status
chancellor scholl so germany says the
eu's got to reform its voting rules
before it can admit new member countries
um
it feels that though it's a great
gesture the likelihood of ukraine
joining the eu anytime soon
seems rather small well uh trevor let's
pause uh one second about the historic
dimension of what we did this week in in
in brussels what our leaders agree it's
not not only giving ukraine moldova and
georgia a clear european perspective
meaning you are part of the family you
can be members of the european union it
was given
ukraine and moldova
candidate status meaning that from
this week they are candidates to join
the european union there's a long path
ahead of course if i take my own case of
portugal small country in the west in
the west of europe it took us nine years
uh to get a full membership of the
european union it implies a lot of
reforms it implies a lot of alignment of
of policies and structures and
legislation and rules inside ukraine but
the signal we're given the signal we're
giving this week is absolutely crucial
if you went asked me a year ago if
that that will be a likelihood before
the invasion before everything that
happened i would be very skeptical about
it today i'm i'm enthusiastic about the
prospect of giving our ukrainian friends
who are suffering so much this clear
european perspective well you say
there's a clear european perspective but
i think that you will understand it
ukrainians are taking this with a little
bit pinch of salt when um
the member states themselves haven't
presented an exactly united front mr
macron wants to give vladimir putin uh
concessions and it's on the phone to him
all the time as far as we can make out
germany
accused of dragging its feet over
weapons supplies
you can see why president zielinski
desperately wants to join the eu but
feels maybe the eu
is supportive
in words but not necessarily in deeds we
are supportive but we are also
responsible the last thing i think we
should
provide the ukrainians with is is false
hopes or false promises we need to be
realistic accession to full membership
will take time it will take effort on
the ukrainian side it will also
force us to certainly adapt some of our
structures some of our policies in order
to you know it's a 44 million people
country large territory
coming into the union of course this
requires efforts on both sides but let
me be clear this was a unanimous
decision and i think it's very important
to note our countries have evolved you
you name some some of our leaders that
maybe a few months ago had more doubts
than they had this week so the union
went a long way to address uh the the
needs and the requests and the
aspirations of the ukrainian uh
ukrainian people i i i and you're a
diplomat and i know you uh would shy
away from anything that he seemed even
mildly critical of any of the eu's
members but um
over the past week gazprom the russian
gas supplier
it's it's cut the supply through the
nordstrom pipeline by 60
um
do you think
that the russians could actually
undermine eu solidarity because frankly
the germans depend on that bulgarians
depend on on that
and that
this is pressure that could crack that
solidarity open travel let me
look back to the last few months
if if president putin's hope and goal
was to divide us if his goal and hope
was to divide nato if it was to divide
the uk from the eu on this type of
issues it totally failed we have
likely enlarged nato we have a
strengthened european union we have very
good cooperation with uk as far as
ukraine and russia is concerned and we
have adopted six packages of sanctions
you know targeting more than 1 200
people 100 entities we are cutting off
the the supply of oil
by the end of the year and of course on
gas you
you mentioned get this is extremely
sensitive for our country so there's one
thing we should never do
is to apply sanctions that hurt us more
then it hurt
our main target and we need to make sure
that we we we sustain the support of our
voters
to to the sanctions so they are
calibrated they are measured but they
are i can guarantee you hitting very
hard the heart of the russian economy
all right let's turn to a story which um
we've just been talking about with uh mr
lewis and also with mr lammy and that is
a report that the
government is planning to introduce
steel tariffs to protect the uk steel
industry um some people believe that
these would break the wto world trade
organization rules um
we are staring down the barrel of a
trade dispute possibly a trade war
aren't we
well well i don't know the measures i
cannot comment on them but in general
terms uh i don't think protectionism is
the solution for any of our problems of
course we need to be attentive to the
rules of the game if everybody in in the
in the world trade scene is following
them or not and when we find this kind
of when we find this kind of
non-compliance we are very tough as well
when it needs be so again i cannot
comment on this but i think our
economies are facing a very difficult
very difficult times largely because you
we are just coming out of the kovitz
cycle and trying to implement very
ambitious recovery uh measures and we
are hit by the consequences of the war
which by the way are not only hitting us
if you look at the seed food so food
security situation in the world i mean
the russian troops are occupying the
fields they are blocking the ports they
are destroying the infrastructures in
ukraine and they are assuming a very
heavy load of responsibility in terms of
creating possibly a wave of famine in
the world so it all goes back to
to what's happening in ukraine and
russia that's why it's so important that
we remain united the eu and uk and we're
doing a good job on that the eu itself
nato the whole western world but also
that we bring on board countries from
the south
because this is also their their concern
you um
are coming to the end of your term here
you'll be leaving moving on uh
moving on to something even more
glorious at the end of this year that's
exactly the case more glorious
you said that you believe in life after
brexit um
that's true for britain but it's also
true for the european union yeah what
what do you envisage as the future for
this large european union with all the
strains not just the the war the ukraine
war but all the other things that are
going on
how is the eu going to hold together i
think i'm i'm i'm
maybe more optimistic than i was maybe a
couple of years ago what i've seen in
our reaction to brexit where we stayed
united no other country even
thought of considering leaving and
public opinion support has
been strengthened if i look at the
reaction to kovid where we
we we were together responding to this
crisis and responding in terms of
recovery if i look at ukraine situation
i was even surprised let me say very
clearly by by by the boldness and the
and the strength of our response to
ukraine so if i if i take this uh very
recent crisis which we dealt with with
in a very solid way i'm positive about
the union but we will have always to
adapt to new circumstances it's a it's a
it's a living animal and that that's
what makes it so fascinating ambassador
thank you very much for joining us thank
you i wish you well in the next phase of
your distinguishing i'm still here for a
few months
thank you very much